talking about miners obviously uh if we
go back to kind of q1 of 2021 uh mining
was 65 in china and spread out the rest
uh throughout the world uh china banned
it we had a migration to the united
states i think the u.s now is over 30
percent of all uh hash rate globally
texas has like 10 percent something like
that um
what are the ramifications of price
going down for the miners and should we
expect any kind of uh pressure from them
or does this actually benefit them so
this is another shoe to drop i hate to
tell you all but um miners have like
public miners if you add it up they've
got go to like bitcointreasures.com
they've got like 40 50 000 bitcoin
sitting there
so they've got almost one
tara's worth of bitcoin you know there's
a lot of bitcoin they have because the
public market's rewarded the miners that
accumulate a lot of bitcoin didn't sell
it that was sort of the metagame get as
much bitcoin as possible don't sell it
so it's a pro cyclical
phenomenon it means that they make the
bull market steeper and the bear markets
worse
the same thing happened in 2018. miners
i think the last leg down
in 2018 or 2019 to 3 000 i think that
actually was minor selling driven
um if you sort of like do the uh the
ancient archaeology now if you look on
chain i know people say like on chain
has no alpha or whatever just look at it
guys there's some interesting stuff
there
um
miners are
selling well you don't have to look on
chain you could look at the balance
sheets you look at the sec blockchain or
like look at the sec filings right the
sec
yeah yeah it's on it's all it's all on a
ledger somewhere yeah so miners are
selling their bitcoin they have a lot
more bitcoin to sell and they're going
to sell it for a number of reasons a lot
of them are out of business they can't
afford their next payment um they're
just not going to exist in a year's time
so there can be insolvencies there a lot
of them are too highly levered and
they're not going to be able to pay
their uh pay their bills um
whether it's power or they're not going
to be able to make interest payments um
and they'll be out of business
a lot of miners will buy the now
bankrupt competitor miners
they're gonna buy with bitcoin on their
balance sheet right um or cash but you
know bitcoin is a liquid asset that
they've ready to go so there'll be a
wave of consolidation all that means is
that a lot of the bitcoin that the
miners accumulated will be liquidated
and this has kind of been my view since
we saw the liquidations in 2018 as
miners are this pro cyclical force
which i think is a very different view
from like the stock to flow narrative
where you know
the stock to flow narrative it doesn't
uh incorporate what minor behavior
really is and their actual behavior is
during the you know bull phases they
want to hold the bitcoin and then during
market downturns they're forced to sell
the bitcoin
and uh we haven't seen that completed
yet but i think we will
and so for me that would be actually
bottom signal once they're done
liquidating all their bitcoins